foreign
welcome it's great to see you here in
the Oval Office in Washington and by the
way happy birthday
Colombia
or a Latin America
and it was yesterday 19th of April is a
very important date for Colombia for
Latin America and for me as well
it's very difficult turning 40 years of
age
they say that in this generation they
haven't been 63 is like being 40 in the
old generation I fully subscribed
Mr President I've long believed as you
probably know that uh
Colombia is the key to the hemisphere
and I mean that's sincerely the Keystone
and I think we have an opportunity if we
work at it hard enough
to have a western hemisphere that is
United equal Democratic and
and and
economically prosperous
together
Columbia the United States are leading
an effort to deal with climate change
and to I've been working for a long time
we make it we're going to make a 500
million dollar commitment to
deal with uh
preserving Amazon
um
and working through the America's
partnership for economic prosperity
we're working to grow our economies
from the bottom up in the middle now not
from the top down
foreign
I know we share one of you very
passionate with that
it's inherent the inherent dignity and
the rights of individual workers
[Music]
we're also working together to Counter
Narcotics trafficking and addressing
historic levels of migration in our
hemisphere especially through the Darien
Gap
area
and Mr President I want to thank you for
the hospital and support
Colombia continues to show to Venezuelan
refugees
it's a humanitarian and generous thing
for what you're doing
images
and as I know you know we're working
closely with regional Partners to help
Colombia meet this challenge which is
consequential and uh and costly
yeah
and I really want to thank you for your
outspoken and
strong commitment to peace and human
rights across the Americas you speak to
it all
right
as we began the next Century of our
partnership I believe we can do even
more to deepen and develop a cooperation
so I want to thank you again for taking
the time to be here and look forward to
our conversations
DNA
Elementos
history
the Americas has across all the
countries two common elements in its
history
[Music]
unlike other parts of the world our
countries grew
ever since their founding under the
concepts of democracy and freedom
foreign
the concept of democracy and freedom is
not etched in stone rather it is a flow
it flows along and it evolves with
history
uh in and becomes ever more profound
um
foreign
so we are going down the same river a
river that leads us to ever greater
democracy and ever greater freedom
is
we also share in common that in this
hemisphere there's almost never been
Wars between the Nations between the
peoples
we are well accustomed to peace and not
work
therefore democracy freedom and peace
constitute our common agenda
Ramos
oi
Lao Manida El planeta
and if we look at the economy today
humankind and the whole earth calls for
an in-depth thoroughgoing economic
change
foreign
we need to move from a fossil fuel sort
of capital or fossil the covering of
fossil fuel which has evolved like a
hurricane that is increasingly
threatening our existence
to an economy that does not use coal oil
or gas Pilates
La Paz
Ada
if we put together these pillars
of political and economic on the
political side democracy freedom and
peace and on the economic side building
decarbonized economies then I think we
can have a common Destiny whereby this
region of the Americas can become a
beacon for all humankind
in Las Americas
libertad
a general major potential energy
Olympics
I believe that humankind and the
Americas May well have the greatest
potential for democracy and freedom in
the Americas as well as the greatest
potential for green energies
so we have a common agenda and a lot of
work today
thank you so much for having received me
in your house well I couldn't agree with
you more by the way this morning I had a
teleconference with 10 other nations of
preparation the next couple meetings
and I honestly believe we're making some
real progress
moving toward carbon-free
yes
one of the things we may talk about is
how we
Panama
Colombia for your electric needs
but that's for longer discussion thank
you